and this is just a really quick one um
there is a 73 year old bodybuilder that
went on to America's Got Talent and I
just wanted to show this to Ryan talking
about here is my here is my inspiration
my name is Terry Crews took his shirt
off
yes Jack he's jacked 73 years old that's
crazy
no not I'm not trying to one-up this
lady she's had no work done our face
that's cool
here's the other thing my uncle pax was
71 we won mr. universe Jack to the gills
really I've been back spiel but that's
impressive though no that's that's cool
well it's what's impressive visitor her
skin so tight like her stomach there's
no there's no you know this is she
definitely it's done I didn't say so
again
b.o.b EA le mr. universe if you go to
him what he was like sitting there on
his back he was senior mummy one their
senior mr. universe right there yep Wow
Jesus whoa Wow mr. Boddy bill until he
was frickin I mean 50 was a boxer right
Olympic boxer son GI yep yeah he was
your favorite huh my favorite yep never
touched a steroid yeah so my joke I know
it's gonna say this yeah probably not
true nope not true it all works for him
and that's after he had bypass heart
surgery
you just I started doing bodybuilding
good god is that him
no if you go up to it where he's flexing
he's on stage there chin you see him
yeah there he is he's 60 something there
dude
that's [ __ ] crazy nuts you know what
you're gonna be doing in your future
buddy yeah they're both in shape she
that outfit is one of the greatest
things I've ever seen
well he would wear that one go-to did
no he would not dude I'm judge he would
he would only wear body burn clothes
that everywhere we went
dude five-star restaurants we're in San
Francisco give this old royal
rolls-royce you just hit cars in like
Park and get out and like you're in
spandex packs you'd go the top steak
houses but everyone knew mr. Venice and
he'd be walking like that [ __ ] Wow
always in something that was very
form-fitting its addressed every time
that is a colorful man oh dude he's the
legend Jesus good for him good frame is
right strong guy that's big weight
yeah playful but yeah yeah man oh man
whoa well she's no joke either he has to
be 80 something there Jones right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue Oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]